so when you're talking about you
launched your own line it's called give
Beauty so why did you name it that
because you I assume you like to give
Beauty like you give that kind of kind
of gift that's awesome it's definitely
one of those things I feel like it's
with makeup you put your makeup on and
you're giving to other people with with
your with what you're doing right like
you put the effort in and you don't go
around looking at yourself all day late
long unless you're like instagramming
yeah yeah but I'm saying like it's also
like this time in my life like everybody
knows I went through a really
challenging time yeah a few years ago
and I kind of reassessed everything I
had to start over with so many things
and just hard to do it's really hard
yeah and I just was like what am I going
to do with the rest of my life and I
know I have to be creative in some way
or I'll just feel like a person yeah so
I and makeup is always before music it
was makeup I was a makeup artist on a
you know at the mall oh it was I didn't
know that not for a long time yeah but
it was like my dream because I actually
worked in Plaza sportswear and like you
know polyester pants for older women and
I really did actually enjoy that because
I was good at that too I
I'm coming and they'd be desperate like
help me find an outfit and I would love
that it's a gift to be able to know how
to help that situation I do I love that
and so I just looked up to the girls
over on the counter that I was like I
want to be one of those girls like I
want to be behind the counter I know I
can do it and finally I don't they just
open the door they didn't even train me
they didn't tell me what to do they were
like oh wow just make a display and sell
makeup and so I started doing it but the
joy of it was when people would come in
and just want like free samples or want
you to do their makeup for free because
they were going to go out or whatever
and maybe buy something from you but
yeah it was like the way they felt when
I would do their makeup the way I feel
when I wake up and look at myself and
then after my makeup's done like it's
just that feeling so I feel it's very
it's like this giving feeling so that's
kind of where it came from no it's a
blessing because my my it is it's a
blessing for people they can do it
because I literally like come into this
studio like a different human and like
and then and then really like and I like
that human she's great she looks fine
but like when my Glam Squad gets I call
them Harry Potter collectively because
literally what you're able to do when
you can do that is you transform it and
you feel different and you feel you feel
different you carry yourself it is
different I agree I just I just love I
I'm surprised because you're you love
crafting you're super I love that I
would think that yeah I'd be good at
makeup
and I didn't want to ask you in case it
wasn't okay so yeah I was
but that's amazing
for people like me I've struggle to find
things especially eye stuff and that's
why it is hard and yeah the thing is
that it's super challenging because when
you're creating the formulas for clean
makeup it's like
to have high performance like real
artistic level makeup that's like really
dense colors and stuff like that it is
challenging so like for it to finally be
out and then we also launched this this
is really cool if you love makeup or you
talk about the community part of it yes
yes I'm so glad you're talking about
this because I saw you talking about an
interview I think it was with Seth Marsh
and I love this part tell everybody
about they get to be a part of it right
yeah because I feel like every there is
a makeup community community out there
there's people that blog makeup that
love makeup that are obsessed like I am
with makeup and they're already doing it
there's also like people that just
follow me that promote me because they
feel like they want to and I'm like
I want to feel like at this point in my
life how do I include them so basically
we started this ambassador program where
you can actually just sit at home and
sell the makeup from your phone and make
but they come up with their own stuff
too that's how they can sell it too
because I they can do their own
tutorials they get like all of the
information from us and then get a code
and then people can shop through their
Instagram however they want to do it and
they they just get they get the
commission so it's just cool they just
they're doing what they're probably
already doing anyways but they're going
to get some money for it so I think it's
kind of cool to be able to I think it's
cool you've probably got commission
anytime you've sold I think it's cool
that full circle moment it's just like a
fun kind of game to play really just be
out there and everyone's it's so fun for
me to troll on all these people that are
taking the makeup and and making it
theirs like you know what I'm saying
because they they do things with it that
I wouldn't do you know it's just a very
creative place to expect it might
inspire you to do something Inspire
other people it's pretty cool I like it
I like the full circle wait can we see
the makeup because I oh hey what up Trey
what's up Justin oh my God look at that
train they made it look at Kelly
Clarkson's show coming through I'm like
I didn't see that before this is so cute
okay so wait we brought this out to show
because
um well Gwen has a special surprise for
everyone here give Beauty by Gwen
Stefani she might not have known but
it's happening I think now you're saying
it oh my God give Beauty by Gwen Stefani
is a clean high performance color
Cosmetics brand created for the
community of creative people who love
makeup you can shop their products at
givebeauty.com but today everyone in the
audience is going home with Gwen's
signature look worth over two hundred
dollars
[Applause]
[Music]